monsieur vous nous avez téléphoné ce
matin en nous disant venez d'urgence ici
dans ce café pourquoi bain voici
monsieur nous sommes sur la rue avec nos
enfants quand tu l'apprends pas et nous
savons pas où aller nous avons fait
beaucoup de l'asile avec les agents
d'ailleurs du 13e la place d'italie qui
nous ont conduit le soir dans les asiles
toutes sortes d'asile quoi pour pouvoir
nous loger alors qu'est-ce que vous avez
travaillé en dernier ressort bac en
dernier ressort nous sommes et des aléas
à la gare de service pour pouvoir
coucher
depuis combien de temps ça fait trois
jours que nous y sommes et comme je
voulais j'avais été voir les agents pour
ça parce que la première nuit on on
arrivait à peine les ja allonger les
enfants allons nous sommes debout toute
la nuit et c'est pas une solution
les enfants on peut pas les nettoyer
comme on veut oui à ce propos mme adam
khel à quel est l'âge de ces enfants et
comment faites-vous précisément pour et
nourrir ses enfants et malgré tout leur
donner les soins dispensés dans un hall
de gare et pelles et vibrant le café est
ouvert
jusqu'en lozère ont fait chauffer les
biberons nuk intense et qui va fermer en
vain de faire languir et enlever mon
mari veut mais selon radial terre de
sous la banquette peut qu'il soit chaud
c'est floride
monsieur collet pourquoi et tout à la
rue en fête
ben voila je j'étais chez mes parents
depuis sept ans enfin à moins d'être
marié j étais et je me suis marié j'ai
été toujours été chez mes parents vous
comprenez je fais mes enfants j'avais
fait une demande de logement il ya sept
ans et pour des raisons personnelles
comme je vous ai dit et j'ai été obligé
de partir
nous étions douze dans trois petites
pièces et c'était pour toi je dis vive
vous comprenez que ça arrivait à perdre
et d'ailleurs madame que comptez-vous
faire ce soir
où comptez vous dormir ici on n'a rien
encore par la carmi et demain on s'est
pas vous m'aviez parce que le café nous
on y lit ferme demain et la saison est
déjà prise parce que lire beaucoup de
cafés qui font pas ce qu'ils font
il nous appartient pas maintenant de
connaître les causes exactes de cette
situation mais par contre vous en
connaissez les conséquences dans une
demi heure maintenant dans moins d'une
demi-heure cette famille de quatre
enfants va repartir dans le froid peut
être même dans la neige pour aller
coucher pour aller essayer de dormir un
peu dans une salle d'attenté de gare le
problème est que faut-il faire